hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my flash season 5 episode 22 finale
video so obviously they're all setting
up crisis on Infinite Earths on all the
different air / shows in the finale
so also address that during the video
too but if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment about the episode on the
video so obviously spoiler warning for
the flash finale also address some of
the stuff that happened during the arrow
finale too at the end of this top 10 WTF
and easter eggs here we go number 10
Ralph is a full blast of amira gun and
it just completely messes him up
although they did kind of tease mirror
world a little bit because Caitlin says
all the cells are inverted somehow so
that might be more mirror master stuff
that they're teasing in season 6 because
they tease McCullough industries so
maybe we'll see Evan McCullough mirror
master is a villain during season 6 at
some point after a crisis there were a
whole bunch of season 1 references
throughout the episode but one of the
ones they made early while they were
trying to fix elongated man was the Lady
Gaga song that they played when Barry
first woke up they also reused the song
when Nora woke up for the first time
after Godspeed accidentally reactivated
her powers the first half of the episode
for the most part was really just
dealing with the gray cicada stuff I was
not a fan of cicada this season so I'm
really happy that they only spent the
first bit of the episode dealing with
that then they did all the reverse-flash
and crisis stuff the back half of the
episode so number 9 they figure out that
they have to get rid of the dagger in
order to get rid of cicada it finally
all works out both versions of cicada
because you have the mindspace cicada
the Grace has in her mind when she's an
adult both of them chewing is much
scenery as they can get their hands on I
don't know who the director was on set
for all their scenes but they should
have told him to pull it back just a
little bit yes they're playing a villain
on a comic book show but that doesn't
mean they're to be so over the top with
it either way they erased her from the
timeline so cicada isn't a thing anymore
let us never speak of cicada again the
explainer for why they had to get rid of
the dagger was one it was taking their
powers away so they
were totally vulnerable but it was also
blocking the cure in young Grace's mind
so as soon as they sat the dagger with a
mere gun the cure started working again
that's when older gray started to be a
race from the timeline is the same
effect when Nora got erased from the
timeline it's all a bunch of dominoes
being knocked over one at a time by
reverse flashes it's all part of this
long con he's been pulling the last 15
years but like he explained her in the
episode and this is on my list here too
it goes all the way back to the flash
100th episode when they visited him in
the past
so obviously number eight reverse flash
gets his powers back because the daggers
gone in the future so he kills all the
guards just in time because they were
getting ready to kill him with negative
Speed Force energy how ironic that they
were trying to kill him with a source of
his own power the line gentlemen I hate
to inform you but you're all dead is
actually an easter egg for when he
killed Cisco during season one when he
was talking to Cisco though he said
forgive me but to me you've been dead
for centuries then boom he faces his
hand right through Cisco's chest he
referenced that again at the end of the
episode when Cisco showed up with team
flash to fight him in the future
he also repeats a line from that same
episode where he killed Cisco when he
says in many ways Nora has shown me what
it's like to have a daughter in that
episode he tells Cisco in many ways
you've shown me what it's like to have a
son he also said this is the second time
I've been stuck somewhere for 15 years
also referencing season 1 because when
he got into the accident with Barry when
he came back to kill his mother he had
to wait around for Barry to grow up and
become the flash 15 years later so that
he could steal his Speed Force powers
from him and you have the events of
season 1 play out 7 was Nora rewinding
time after he killed all those guards it
was a really badass move to and him
going after the guard that had been
torturing him this whole time for the
last 15 years very cathartic moment for
Rupert's flash but because of what Nora
and Barry did they're all still alive in
the future and they changed the timeline
quite a bit so there's probably other
changes happening in the future that
I'll talk about in a second they
confront him about manipulating Nora
this whole time he admits to everything
sorry this is all part of a long con but
I got this idea when you came back to
visit me in the past and asking how to
get rid of cicadas dagger so when he was
imprisoned in the future he knew
instantly when he saw cicadas dagger
that he would have to wait for Nora to
show up and ask for his help so he would
give her the idea to go back
the satellite and they would create a
version of cicada they would start all
these events that would help him
eventually get out of prison so it's a
whole lot of moves and manipulations
along the way but the kind of explains
what the time loop was just another
example of how them messing with the
time line hurts them in the long run but
like father like daughter he even gave
her the flash point explainer at the
beginning of the episode like Jay
Garrick gave him it's not quite the
coffee cup explainer but it's basically
the same thing where he says you have to
decide what kind of hero you're gonna be
are you gonna be a hero that takes a
do-over every time you make a mistake
flashpoint being a huge do over the
Barry took for himself or are you gonna
learn to live with your mistakes
reverse-flash challenges them to a fight
poses wring out for a second time and
then they're off they have a pretty cool
fight before team flash shows up so
number six reverse flash pulls a god
speed move they finally brought a
version of god speed to the TV show so
I'm not surprised that they're pulling
more Easter eggs from that flash rebirth
run if you've been reading the flash
comics you probably recognize the god
speed move instantly so reverse flash
when he splits himself into two isn't
creating a time remnant because he then
just phases both versions back into
himself and you don't do that with time
remnants they fight Barry and Nora
separately and sort of misdirect them so
the thing about this in the comics is
that God speed calls himself god speed
because only God has the ability to be
in all places at the same time god
speeds signature move is splitting
himself into two making himself seem
like two different people when really
it's just two aspects of the same person
but the problem that when he does that
is that both of his aspects become much
weaker so you can actually kill one and
you'd have like a half a version of God
speed left he'd still be the same person
he just wouldn't be nearly as powerful
as before he split himself so this web
reverse flash pulls himself back
together before he tries to finally kill
Barry but obviously team flash shows up
and they fight him reverse flash then
number five calls out the Ralphs did
knee caught nudie air from season one
did I get so many questions about every
single season on the show hey did you
see that scene where Ralph kidney was
mentioned by you Barth on during season
one what happened with that he was
supposed to die in the particle
accelerator explosion the reason why I
think that happened is is because during
season one when Farooq was coming for
Harrison wells to blame him for the
death of all of his friends at STAR Labs
in the particle accelerator explosion
the writers just needed a whole bunch
names to list off and they wanted to
include some Easter eggs from the comics
like here a couple cool comic book
characters that died during this without
knowing that many years down the road
they would want to actually use the
elongated man Ralph's kidney character
on the show so when they named him
during season one they did not know that
he would be coming on the show later the
way that most of the fans explained it
was just by saying that it was a
flashpoint side effect because remember
when Barry did flashpoint then tried to
fix everything it didn't quite go back
to normal there was still a couple minor
changes but number four Nora gets a
raise from the timeline because of all
the changes they've made in eliminating
cicada it was all part of reverse
flashes plan he knew that she was going
to be erased that's why he says I'm
sorry little Runner but I had to do this
to ensure that I would escape so he knew
all this time that she was gonna wind up
getting a race from the timeline but
here's the thing though he also probably
knows that Nora herself isn't supposed
to exist she's actually supposed to be
dawn one-half of the tornado twins and
she's supposed to have a twin brother
also named dawn remember the hundredth
episode because reverse-flash says
that's how I got the idea for this whole
plan was cicadas dagger to free myself
from prison because you came back to
visit me during the hundredth episode
and asked about it
it's uh dawn if I'm not mistaken when he
sees Nora for the first time he thinks
that she's his daughter in her name is
dawn which is obviously a big comic book
think dawn alland one-half of the
tornado twins but she says no my name is
Nora so he knows instantly the timeline
has already changed meaning that
something happened in there are no more
tornado twins they just have one
daughter
so because the future is changing so
much it's likely that when we see Nora
again she will be the tornado twins and
she'll have a brother and they'll
finally pay off that season 4 episode 1
Easter Egg were gonna need more diapers
I think it's because they're waiting for
the tornado twins to show up at some
point next season during crisis on
Infinite Earths and they'll find some
way of referencing that so r.i.p Nora
she had to die so that the tornado twins
could live also remember if things as
big as say Nora are being erased from
the timeline then most anything that you
saw during the Godspeed episode could
potentially be very very different in
the new version of the timeline so if
you were unhappy with Godspeed this is
their chance to rewrite that character
and introduce a much cooler version of
Godspeed in a future episode 3
reverse-flash says see you at the next
crisis obviously referencing crisis on
Infinite Earths because he knows that
that's coming up really soon remember
reverse flashes from the future so he
knows all about when the flash
disappears how he disappears the
circumstances behind it so it's no
coincidence that he's saying crisis but
he also probably knows about the
advanced timeline and how crisis is now
happening during 2019 instead of 2024
remember reverse flash is mentioned
during Barry's future newspapers so that
to pay off some of those Easter eggs to
reverse flash leads an army of shadow
demons so shadow demons all over the
place during this year's crisis
crossover so number 2 all the end
credits scenes teasing stuff for the
flash season 6 Captain scene becomes the
new police commissioner so Joe West is
going to be the new captain of the
police department so we'll probably have
more scenes at the police department
just because he'll be localized there
most of the time
big ones cisco takes the cure so he's
not going to be vibe anymore because he
doesn't want reverse flashes
manipulation to be the reason why he
became special it's kind of a weird
explainer because Carlos Valdez the
actor that plays Cisco doesn't want to
be on
the show is irregular anymore but he
will come back every once in a while of
course he's gonna come back for the
crossover next year but he's not going
to be a series regular anymore it seems
like so this is basically him leaving
the show he makes a really special new
comic book costume for killer frost we
don't see exactly what it's going to
look like but obviously that's gonna
debut during next year's crossover so
it'll probably be really cool they go
into the Time Vault with Barry and iris
in Nora's time journal because remember
it's written in a language that's
impervious to timeline changes so no
matter what future version of the
tornado twin shows up they'll still have
Nora's journal from that earlier
timeline she left them a little message
just like reverse-flash left Barry a
message remember at the beginning of
season two that's the whole reason he
was able to get his father out of prison
one of the bigger flash season six
teases is when Ralph opens a case file
that says Dearborn on it sue did knees
name his wife from the comics her maiden
name is Dearborn so it sounds like
they're going to introduce sue did knee
next year but number one the crisis on
Infinite Earths scene at the very end so
the clock starts rolling back timeline
changes processing in the clock just
rolls back from 2024 to 2019 the date of
this year's crossover and the reason why
the camera sort of fudges out before you
see the exact day is probably because
the CW network isn't sure which week is
actually going to air the official
crossover episodes but like I said
pretty much all of arrow season 8 is
gonna be crisis episodes with them
dealing with Christ's on Infinite Earths
stuff they'll probably do a lot of that
in the first half of the season of the
flash tube building up into the official
crossover so what I'll do is is I'll do
a crisis teaser video with all the
scenes from the show's together to
explain what's happening at the
beginning of crisis next year but while
you wait for everything click here for
my Game of Thrones finale trailer video
and click here for my Watchmen HBO
series trailer video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you